and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review the Avengers
oh my dad did your greatest movie I've
ever seen in my life
no I'm serious it's the greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life okay look I'm
gonna do the bid free and everything but
you guys really have to know this is
like probably one of the greatest movies
ever I mean it's just unbelievable it's
like a miracle of a film it's just like
all this stuff comes together and it's
funny it's actor bait holy crap I mean
it's just okay I'm gonna put this back
on I just you have to assure me that
you're gonna see it okay it's just
promise me
maybe that promise okay good Tyler's
dear sees pirate corn Nick Fury he's
like this is motherfucking guy who wants
to go from my motherfucking world of
course it apparently the guys name is
Loki and he stole this magic Rubik's
Cube and Loki is like I want to wear
goat helmet to take over the world but
why because this Friday and I have
nothing better to do
I spent my Fridays like that once it
didn't work so Nick Fury is like we need
a team of the most brightly colored
bull's-eyes we can find so he puts
together the Avengers hey as long as uma
Thurman refine czar out of it I'm good
though I would like Sean Connery as a
teddy bear it just makes sense to me so
all the Avengers come together including
Iron Man The Hulk lack Widow Captain
America Thor weapon hue PTP grumpy dopey
jiggy Smith and the Saturday Night Live
band with your host Steve Martin so
they're off to stop lucky and they're
like low-key okay well those easy
beefing jersey avenge things though not
really actually they take a look into
this giant Cruiser
what's our looks like a flying version
of battleship yeah yeah I saw the
trailer for that too just keep telling
yourself the adventures came out this
year I'm gonna be okay and in theory is
like I've found with demigods only
weakness glass but Loki is like I have a
diabolical plan to turn the Avengers
against each other and Avengers are like
ah that'll never work
he's it we what are you talking about I
think that would definitely work you're
an idiot you're an idiot a broad but
then Loki's men attack and the Avengers
are like we never should have fought and
just gotten along I don't agree with
that
money theory is like I'm sick of these
motherfucking bad just motherfucking
arguing we got a motherfucking Wizard of
Oz villain ready to destroy the earth
and your mother fuck he's motherfucking
right to all the Avengers get together
mother like a hairy panicky you get
angry and turn to the Hulk and Eric
Banner is like here's the secret
I've always angry hey that makes no
sense if he's always angry when he
always be the Hulk it's confusing enough
he doesn't look like the guy from Fight
Club anymore
so he gets all these alien creatures
that come from another dimension and I'm
like who are these alien creatures the
audience was like hold it I think I've
those stuff up in a minute yes yes yes
I'm good hey boys you like blow stuff up
I amazed like Jesus and Flores like
lightning lightning lightning hello kids
like Smurfs Smurfs Smurfs and I'm like
Gaza it's like imagine in Michael Bay
had money and the need to destroy things
but he wasn't a horny neanderthal
this is the movie you would make so
these are exploring physics but the
League of shadowy people who decide
things for like nuke the city
can't we just throw the nuke into the
portal okay I guess it works too I make
you get on that gee thanks so Iron Man
throws the nuke into the portal the
portal is destroyed
Loki's punished pike given a muzzle for
some reason and he owned it avenge for
the other actor Avengers avenge to us
means beating the crap out of things
with an Athena the credits they're like
I am giant cherry faced man and only
extreme comic-book geeks will know what
this means and everybody in the audience
was like yeah
shut up he's Birdman and or Wolverine
gonna be in the next one passively kyun
typed so the Avengers is great why are
you even still watching this review just
go sit sit sit
seriously see it this is just to me boom
sing chide you got giant I come on epic
eyewear yes tonight judge all proceeds
will go to a promise to keep the whole
theater team after this money will go to
direct